thanks have ruined for tuning in we are
testing our zoom h6 recorder with this
video file we're gonna see if this by
chance solves the big problem that we
are in fact facing Ori
do you want to talk a little bit for us
please I wonder why it says left and
right or we can do it we do have to talk
back and forth a bit get that yeah yeah
yeah okay cool good that's you is it
your face sounds good yeah no you do
that a lot it's funny yeah I find it
funny because it's again it's very
different than what everyone else does
in their lives that's what we're talking
about that's great it the looks even the
looks even better when there's two
people that can
we can do it at the same time yeah yeah
yeah oh it's so good it's so good you
actually do that so they're like do you
fight other people or I don't think of
do what I don't know if I've seen you do
it on there people too much maybe a
little bit maybe it's because I feel
yeah honestly it feels like a purifier
feels like this energy balancer energies
so it just kind of comes through it's
like this shot of intensity yeah it
might look like anger yeah my intention
is shot of intensity a shot a balancing
shot of intent because usually the
conversation is going oh yeah and it's
love it's a pure love it's actually it's
actually just loving intensity loving
intensity yeah that's what is
interesting I like it when it comes
mid-sentence from you I think it carries
more weight than if you're just looking
if other people are talking and then if
you're doing it and they like a look at
you then it's good but it carries more
weight when it actually it it it
probably carries the most weight when
you do it mid-sentence but then it
probably carries the second-most weight
when the person's looking at you and
then you go from but you got to do it
like yeah fast is important it's
interesting the shot of intensity the
pace of the shot of intensity like if
it's like if it's like this
but it's not like all right I'm gonna
wield like a shot of intensity as a move
and like as a strategy and like no it's
like um yeah it's like something else
yeah yeah it's interesting that you say
that because to me it's like yeah it's
like it's like a boundary but it's like
the most essential boundary a boundary
yeah but it's like the most essential
boundary it's like setting a boundary so
you set a boundary with the shot of
intensity yeah and the boundary is
supposed to do get the other person to
ask you if you're like how you're
feeling or if you're if you're cool or
if you're okay or a boundary showing the
other person something triggering
something that it was like it is the
other person and I'm just available to
channel the intensity
I love that you brought this up like
it's so cool to like just be talking
about this like yeah spiritual energetic
real phenomenon that like yeah you don't
hear on the cameras yet yeah will do we
could do an actual episode on the
intensity shot which in a sense that's
yeah yeah it's a transmission
it's a transmission it's an energetic
transmission of like a really balanced
high vibrational like truth and so it's
different than like just being like a
human just like being like a person II
like choosing to like make a face and
like it's um there's actually an
exchange of energy there's a
transmission of energy from me to you or
from you to you yeah yeah so in a sense
it's like it's turning this up to five
and a half to see how that handles it
I might actually turn yours up more yeah
yeah let's let's see let's see yours
quick go and talk yeah yeah I'm turning
I'll turn yours to six I think I'll do
mine at five and a half hey everyone um
okay we're now the nine-minute mark see
you went high though there I guess okay
nine-minute mark we're gonna test five
and a half I think we were at five
before this lets test five and a half
now okay or you go ahead and just say a
little bit again
my name is or yeah okay it's fine
so yeah the intensity shot I think that
was enough for now let me go take a
listen to this
thanks everyone I